Music
Here in the garden, let's play a game I'll show you how it's
done
And very still, this will be so much fun.
And then she smiled, that's what I'm after.
A smile in her eyes, a sound of her laughter.
Happy to listen, happy to play, happily watching her drift
away.
Happily waiting, all on my own, under the endless sky.
Counting the seconds, standing alone, as thousands of years
go by.
Happily wondering at night after night, is this how it
works?
Am I doing it right?
to stay happily watching her drift away.
You keep on turning pages for people who don't care, people
who don't care about you.
And still it takes you ages to see that no one's there.
See that no one's there See that no one's there Everyone's
gone on without you Finally something, finally news about
the story ends She doesn't exist now, survived by her son
And all of her brand new friends lovely isn't that cool and
isn't that cool and aren't I a pool to have happily listened
happy this day happily watching her drink drink drink away